they clearly weren't quite dead and
buried but both Liverpool and Tottenham
had the proverbial mountain to climb to
beat two of the best clubs in Europe but
how much did the fabled Bulldog spirit
contribute even in teams with foreign
managers and players something about
English clubs maybe former Tottenham
Star and France international division
are who played for four Premier League
teams thinks there's something extra
with British clubs I think this is
probably the only place in the world
where you can find such things the wheel
of the players the passion around
supporters pushing in the stands
everything is about ok it's not over yet
something the England manager Gareth
Southgate knows all about though as he
told Sky News even he couldn't believe
what he was seeing I was an Enfield on
Tuesday so left there thinking I'd seen
one of the most thing I mean I've been
in football 30 years one of the most
incredible nights I can remember for it
then to be backed up by Tottenham on
Wednesday was phenomenal I mean huge
credit to both managers in different
circumstances they've achieved
incredible seasons but sports
psychologist dr. Josephine Perry says it
may be more about what Barcelona and I
axis players didn't do than what
Liverpool and Tottenham's did if you're
feeling quite comfortable and safe with
your position you don't play the same
way so you'll miss rest on your laurels
you step back a bit you don't have that
same energy and enthusiasm your
activation levels aren't quite as high
enough to get into it and to really
enjoy it and so it won't just be that
the British sighs did brilliantly but
the other side's didn't quite step up as
much as they should off and by the time
they realized they were in trouble it
was too late too late there is though a
sting in the tail two stellar
performances of the two English clubs
could backfire on the national team you
have a nation's League semi-final just
days after the Champions League
makes you have great ideas as a manager
of planning things and working with the
team and in truth we'll have half of our
squad that won't be with us until three
days before so more complicated but
brilliant for for the players and
there's food for thought for those who
believe success is all about money
Liverpool and Tottenham have at least
six teams with deeper pockets than
either of them so who win on June the
1st whoever wants it most
Derry Boden's gaining